famoso malissimo devo dimenticarlo come
facciamo di cosa posso fare per te
andiamo a bere una cosa non hanno voglia
stasera ti prego fallo per me
l'avevo detto che non erano buone idee
andare a bere è duro ma sinceramente
secondo te mi piace oppure no amo ti
avviso in foto
effettivamente non viene benissimo però
dal vivo è troppo buono ma stasera
tumulti tacchi
secondo me ne ha bloccato cioè io io lo
sento vice suo profilo di meter che ha
bloccato
amo ma tu ti sei depilata allora
facciamo così tu adesso leggi questo
messaggio e mi dici cosa ne pensi se per
te va bene io glielo invio subito se c'è
anche solo una parola qualcosa che non
ti convince ci mettiamo qui e lo
riscriviamo perché importante ma senza
grassa una felpa vada cambiarmi amo la
prossima volta che signore voglia di
scrivere ti dà ufficialmente il permesso
di requisire mister emo li riprende
mischiatti ti piace questa foto dal
pubblico oppure no allora il piano è
questo
adesso vai sul profilo di questa claudia
e vai a investigare un posto di lei ma
io voglio che tu vada indietro e gli all
hip hop a scavare nel suo passato
se tu mi trovi anche solo un like di
luca io lascio se mi gira domani vado
dal parrucchiere faccio un taglio
radicale
oppure mi faccio prima la frangia e poi
line station scusa
ciò gli ha messo tre like egli ha
scritto un commento sotto una foto dove
lei era in costume stavano insieme ho
scavato schifo
mandami screenshot nelson l'asso giurami
che non sono da vedere il suo profilo
forse non hai capito cioè non li
rivolgerò mai più la parola quel pezzo
di merda ma neanche se mi si presenta
sotto casa ma un mazzo di rose
beh in quel caso forse no non è più quel
caso ha ragione a massa allora questo
prendo prendo anche questo ma quello
fucsia o dove io non voglio
intromettermi nella tua relazione
assolutamente non voglio influenzati
però sappi che ho un'amica che ha una
cugina che ha una zia che è la vicina di
casa della sorella della madre della
nipote della sorella dell'ex entro
ragazzo io te la butto lì se vuoi
indagare c per un attimo il mio mito
della sera ti ricordi come si chiamava
avevano un po esotico tipo acceso ogni
gionata jack amo non hai capito
ho trovato tutto il suo instagram su
twitter il suo peso il suo gruppo
sanguigno reso intolleranze sul proprio
digitale io sono pazzo ma ti dirò di più
non hai capito cosa ha scoperto che se
questo video rimasti solito mino nike
girano la seconda parte
amo amo
[Musica]